and now it's the turn of the leader of
the Conservatives and the current Prime
Minister David Cameron Prime Minister
thank you very much making it Cheers
okay let's kick straight in Michael
Adams has the first question
and it's a little chance to get an aisle
of the Prime Minister Michael how are
people and zero-hour contracts expected
to pay for their food rent travel and
then expected to pay plan for their
financial futures well what we want
Michael is to make sure we've got decent
jobs for everybody
and in this economy we have seen more
people get work about 1.75 million more
people getting work since I became Prime
Minister but there is no doubt that
you're right there are some zero-hours
contracts where people are abused and so
we've said these zero-hours contracts
where companies can effectively forbid
you from working for anybody else we've
said that is wrong and we've legislated
to stop that now some people though
value having flexible contracts some
individuals value it some businesses and
others value so I don't think it'd be
right to ban these contracts altogether
but it is right to ban the abuse and
that's what we've done is that
convincing for you one of my problems is
I think for young people I think these
contracts can be really good for working
parents and things like that but for
young people would they get pressured
into signing these contracts and working
irregular hours and they don't have any
money and we don't see careers we just
see these dead-end jobs but we don't
actually see careers where we can build
a future well I think you're right
Michael look we want an economy in a
country where if you work hard and you
get the qualifications you should be
able to get a decent job and that's one
of the reasons why we've spent so much
invested so much in apprenticeships
because I think as the Deputy Prime
Minister was saying earlier Nick Clegg
ok the apprenticeship minimum wage is
not that high but the training you get
and the experience you get should mean
you go on to get a really good job
having been an apprentice so my vision
for the country is as you leave school
everyone should have the chance either
of doing an apprenticeship or going to a
university that's that that's what we
should encourage and then you're going
to get more well-paid jobs and fewer
badly paid jobs that that's the key for
the future
okay there's somebody that wants to come
in here at the back let me get a
microphone to you you say that it's good
for people to go to university but at
the same time there are graduates and
undergraduates who have no jobs that are
high employment would you say to this
well what I think is what we should do
as a country is make available
apprenticeships and university places so
that everyone who feels they can benefit
from going to university can go so one
of the things we've done as a government
we they used to be a cap on the number
of students who could go to university
we've taken that cap off so it's
someone's choice whether they want to go
I think we need good careers advice and
schools so we give people better
information about what different choices
can lead to but today in Britain because
we're creating so many jobs because we
got more vacancies than at any time in
recent years in our economy people
coming out of university do have the
chance of getting a job and we need to
help them will have by by applying for
work what works well no there's lots of
work there's lots of jobs being created
here in Britain I mean this take right
we're standing here in London
I became Prime Minister four and a half
years ago compared with four and a half
years ago there's over four hundred
thousand more people in work now of
course some of those will be less well
paid jobs but we've also been creating
jobs in more skilled trades as well so
if you're saying to me look people
leaving University there aren't jobs for
them
we've got more vacancies in our country
than we've had for the last five six
seven years so the jobs are there and I
would advise when it comes to my own
children first in a primary school I'd
advise them as you go through school
think about either doing an
apprenticeship or think about going to
university rather than leaving school at
16 or 18 and I think that's the future
for our country and I think it's good
we've got well-funded
good universities in Britain although
that took as I know you've been
discussing today that took some
difficult decisions about tuition fees
and suchlike but it means our
universities are some of the best
anywhere in Europe and so if you're a
young person in Britain today and you
get to a good school and a good
university you've got every chance of a
good career think Elizabeth just wants
to come back in on this just a
to the fact that I've got to pay tuition
fees but actually I'm really concerned
about the young people who are going to
university and therefore don't have
student finance in place don't have
other resources to help them into that
transition to adulthood and I think the
government needs to be doing more to
support those young people what do you
mean people who are leaving school
without going to university or young
people who believe the university isn't
right for them because on an
apprenticeship as we were earlier
there's not enough to support yourself
and at university I get support with
living which is fantastic young people
at 80 shouldn't feel like they need to
rely on their parents anymore if they
choose not to go to university I don't
think it's good enough for those saying
I think the the right approach for a
country in a in the modern world with
the world changing around us and new
countries on the rise the right thing is
to try to say to young people look
leaving school at 18 rather than having
an apprenticeship or going to university
you're more likely to have a successful
career and a well-paid job if you do one
of the two and the truth is with
apprenticeships actually most people who
do apprenticeships that adds to your
power to earn money later on your life I
was I was at Dagenham the other day the
Ford Works people doing a four-year
apprenticeship there at the end of those
four years I asked them what they're
going to be earning and they were hoping
to earn up to 30,000 pounds after a
four-year apprenticeship so it's a good
thing to do an apprenticeship and that's
why we ask a second question please
thank you
why did Britain fly the Saudi flag at
half-mast if the country has such an
appalling human rights record the reason
for doing that was that there's a
long-standing relationship between the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia and our United
Kingdom here a relationship between our
monarchs the relationship between the
governments we don't agree with lots of
things that the Saudis do we don't agree
with the way they treat people for
instance criminals when we make very
clear those differences but when the
King died as a mark of respect we
thought it was right to show that
respect isn't that disrespectful to the
people who the Saudi King has sentenced
to thousand lashes and you mentioned
that there's a release
you mentioned there's a relationship
between the British government and the
Saudi monarch and vice versa but that's
not a relationship that I'm going to
guess from that judge of a round of
applause that's not a relationship
shared by the citizens look okay I live
out rhinox your questions really
directly because I know how concerned
people worry about that because they
look at things that happen in Saudi
Arabia and think why do we have this
relationship let me tell you as Prime
Minister why I think it's worthwhile we
have a relationship with Saudi Arabia
partly over things like trying to
achieve peace in the Middle East but
crucially over fighting terrorism now I
can tell you please one point I promise
no sharp you've had been employee even
as EDA politicians all day I can tell
you one time since I've been Prime
Minister a piece of information that
we've been given by that country has
saved potentially hundreds of lives here
in Britain now you can be Prime Minister
and just say exactly what you think
about every regime in the world and make
great headlines and give great speeches
but I think my first job is to try and
keep this country safe from terrorism
and if that means you have to build
strong relationships sometimes with
regimes you don't always agree with that
I think is part of the job and that's
the way I do it and that's the best way
I can explain it just on that question
promising Abraham a girl has to follow
up oh yeah so I mean you've spoken about
the relationship that we have and about
how this is informed by fighting
terrorism do you think oil has anything
to do with it yes of course yes I think
it's very important to answer that
question directly and say yes of course
Britain needs to have relationships with
countries that we trade with including
those that we buy oil and gas from we
can't make all our own oil and gas here
in the UK we're doing well because we
got North Sea oil so yes we do have
relationships with these countries but
it's perfectly possible that on a blind
eye to human rights abuses no it's not
what we do it's perfectly possible to go
to those countries as I do and and raise
human rights abuses with them indeed I
would argue if you have a relationship
with them and you have a way of talking
to them they're more likely to listen to
you than if you just cut yourself off
and as I say it's very easy as Prime
Minister to grandstand and make this
features and say this and say that but
actually you have no influence in the
world if you do that whereas if you have
a relationship when you think they're
making a mistake you can say that to
them and I think you want more chance of
being listened to
okay moving on to the next question Sam
with the war on drugs failing
would you consider treating drugs as a
health issue rather than a criminal one
well I think that first of all it's good
that actually drug use in Britain is
going down not up and I think that's
partly because we have been taking not
just a medical approach to it but also a
more educational approach to it the real
focus of this government on drugs it's
not been to change the laws I don't
support that there's still a criminal
offense so we should still go after
people that deal and sell to young
people and all the rest of it but we
have tried to put more emphasis on
educating people properly about the
dangers of drugs and then much more
emphasis on treatment and by treatment I
mean not just giving people substitute
drugs but trying to help get people off
drugs and I think that's partly why we
see drug use coming down so we haven't
cracked it but it's heading in the right
direction but I wouldn't change the
criminal law I think that'd be a mistake
I think for lots of parents they think
hold on I'm trying to keep my children
away from these things and if you change
the criminal law I think you send quite
a signal that it's hard fun for parents
to work out how to talk to their own
children about it so I'd say keep the
law as it is focus on the treatment
focus on the health focus on getting
people clean convinced okay anybody want
to come back on this issue on drugs can
I borrow your microphone again my
dissertation this year is actually on
drug policy yeah and a few years ago you
said that you would reconsider this and
I don't believe anybody who's in
politics is in this for the wrong
reasons you're constrained but it
wouldn't it be better just to say that
and then people would maybe relate to
you more because until you became Prime
Minister here with foreign no no I said
on to Home Affairs Select Committee that
had a good look at this we didn't
actually come down on the side of the
Eagle ization we had a good look at it
look if you're saying politicians are
constrained because they have to think
about what other people think yes that's
true but that's part of being in a
democracy trying to represent people's
opinions understand people's concerns I
I haven't spent a lot of time thinking
about it
I think changing the law and
criminalizing drugs when we're trying to
reduce their use I think that would
probably lead to an increase in their
use so I don't support it but I don't
think the criminal law is the whole
answer to drugs I think the answer to
drugs is Education as treatment and
trying to help people lead drug-free
lives and there as I said I think
there's some signs of success that
you're going to push on to a question
from Facebook which we'll see on the
screen
coming up Christopher it and why are the
Tories going to scrap housing benefit
for 16 to 21 year olds when every
pensioner still gets the winter fuel
allowance well the reason for this is I
think as I've been saying earlier when
young people leave school I think there
should be opportunities to earn by doing
an apprenticeship or getting a job or
opportunities to learn by an
apprenticeship or going to university
but I think the option of leaving school
signing on moving out of home getting a
flat and living on housing benefit I
don't think that is any start to a life
at all so I don't think it should be an
option now of course there are some
people who for whatever reason cannot
live at home and have to be away from
their parents and they we will always
help but the option that some people
have today of leaving school signing on
unemployed getting a flat getting
housing benefit I don't think that is a
good option for young people and I don't
think it should be available anyone on
housing benefit here wants to come back
on that well I think that's a very bad
approach because you use an example of a
small minority of people that just sign
up for the sake of signing on to punish
a large majority of the people who
actually do sign on for so many reasons
you know they have kids so they can't
leave a home because of family issues
and problems as somebody who can
actually live at home at 18 who decided
to go back to Fe College and then are
now at uni house the benefit was the
only way that I could do and I think
that you're making a big mistake by
taking that away from young people well
I don't agree that this is somehow a
tiny minority of people what I'm saying
is if you have to leave home if you
can't stay at home then of course you
should make that benefit available but
today as we speak there is the option as
you leave school to go and sign on to
get unemployment benefit and then to get
a flat and housing benefit I just think
that is a bad way to start your life
it's much better to go on and do either
an apprenticeship or go to university or
go to college or get a job those are
better options and I don't think this
idea that you can say to people it's
okay somehow to
out of working life and training I think
it's a bad approach and we shouldn't do
it
okay over to Brendan for the next
question which is what you do to improve
the housing crisis across the UK and
tackle high rents particularly in London
we got to build more houses there's the
short answer in the end of the day if
you don't have a enough of something it
becomes too expensive either to buy or
to rent so the short answer is build
more houses which we are now doing we've
reformed the planning system houses and
flats are getting built I actually agree
with something Nick Clegg was saying -
which is making sure that as well as the
six-month assured tenancies there are
longer tenancies available as well but
the big thing I'd like to do is build
more homes that young people can buy
what we call starter home so basically
build them for a sell them at 80 percent
of the normal market price and reserve
them and say these are only to be bought
by people under the age of 40
you can't sell them to buy to let land
or to go on and rent them because I
think lots of people who leave school
leave University get a job start working
they're earning enough often to pay a
mortgage but they can't get the deposit
together and I want to see those people
be able to achieve the dream of owning a
flat or a home of their own okay just
put follow-up point on this issue from
Tim Oh Tim it's me that a lot of these
problems recently mentioned all about
the deficit the lack of money yeah and
yet in the past few years while your
government has been in power there just
seems to be money wasted on needless
exercises the budget call for example
that wasted millions of pounds ended up
costing more than it saved it's just you
know let's say the Badger call because
this is probably the most unpopular
policy for which I'm responsible and I'm
gonna try and explain to you Tim why I
think it's the right thing to do we've
lost 500 million pounds by paying
compensation to farmers whose cattle
have caught TB and if we don't do
anything about this scourge of TB which
is by the way terrible for badgers is
what a perfect battle it's gonna cost us
a billion pounds over the next 10 years
now sometimes in politics you've got to
do the thing which you believe is right
even though you know it's unpopular now
I know it is very unpopular culling
badgers but i profoundly believe that
part of the way only part of the way but
part of the way of trying to create some
air is the country that RT be free is to
do this so it's very very difficult but
I believe it's the right thing to do and
that's in the end you know you have to
make choices as a politician sometimes
and sometimes it means doing something
which you know people don't like Tim
sorry steer Mo's to ask about housing
not about badges sorry devolution in
Wales and Scotland and do your party if
you were to win the next general
elections well the short a bright future
for devolution because we've agreed all
the parties have agreed with respect to
Scotland there should be a stronger
Scottish Parliament so whoever wins this
election there'll be a bill in the House
of Commons straight after the election
if I'm Prime Minister it'll be in the
first Queen speech it'll go through
stronger Scottish Parliament I think
we're going to get a stronger Welsh
Parliament to there talks going on right
now and they finish on about the 1st of
March so I think we'll see good progress
there but I want something else which is
I think that it's right that if Scotland
has its Parliament and Wales has its
Parliament and they decide housing and
education and Welfare and things like
that in those countries then it's right
that in the Westminster Parliament when
English MPs are discussing these issues
they should have the decisive say
so-called English votes for English laws
so I want to fix that one - are you
convinced by that Rebecca yeah you are
very cobbler lots of convincing going on
today right let's take one from Facebook
from Karen McDonald which party leader
will eradicate the farcical Prime
Minister's question time don't we have
enough comedies on TV without having
this rerun over and over again and again
this is the look III at five minutes to
twelve every Wednesday I can tell you I
put my head in my hands and think why
have I got to do this it's a nightmare
but does it have a purpose I don't know
maybe you all think it hasn't gone I
think there is there are two points to
it I suppose one is that members of
parliament from whatever party they can
ask you any question they like and so
you've got to try and be on top of your
game and on top of everything that's
happening and that has a knock-on
advantage which is it means that as
Prime Minister you've got to know
everything that's going on in your
government and so it does enforce
some accountability of the departments
and the ministers to you and through you
to Parliament so yes it is noisy and
crazy and infuriating and all the rest
of it but there is some some sort of
point to it does that make any sense
well that's all--that's Chris what do
you think Chris I think pimp use is
horrible I think it's one of the biggest
disengages for voters and I think it's
really petty I think everybody involved
including yourself you stand there you
stand there and you can't you shout and
other members of the House it's
disgusting and I think it's horrible I
have every sympathy I won't say maybe I
get your ticket come and sit in the
House of Commons chamber and you can see
that the noise that is in there and that
is why sometimes you do have to shout
just to try and make yourself heard I
agree it is look it is not
representative of what Parliament does
98% of what Pilate does is scrutinizing
legislation questioning ministers more
responsibly the work of select
committees making sure our laws make
sense I mean there's really good work
done in Parliament this is like one
piece and it is you're right it is like
the sort of Roman circus but I look the
last person to ask to change it you know
what if I change it so do you know what
let's get rid of this I think people
would think you're running away from
accountability I don't think I can do it
but I do wish we could make it a bit
more responsible she let a quick point
on yeah what are you going to do to
engage young people in politics or like
into voting because for as Chris said
like I'm Prime Minister's question time
it's not engaged we just see a load of
people who are supposed to be running
our country and supposed to be more
responsible than us just shouting at
each other and just passing the brim we
don't actually get any answers yeah and
a lot of young people thought well I
can't trust them because I can't even
trust them to act civil and run our
country in a proper way
but then 16 year-olds are Dean's as like
not able to vote because of this when
we've got 40 plus year olds arguing in a
place that's supposed to make laws and
supposed to run our country so I'm just
thinking what are you going to do to
engage young people more and make them
see actually no you can't actually make
a change I think the best thing
investing the ideas of local MP is just
go into secondary schools and sit down
with a sick form
and have a proper reason debate say a
few words about what I think about
politics but then lots of time for loads
of questions and answers and I do that
in secondary schools in my constituency
I try and do it in other parts of the
country I think that's probably the
single best thing because then you're
talking to people whether they're 16 or
18 you know about the things they care
about I think more of that would be a
good thing okay we're gonna move on to
her Nan's question as a young British
Muslim I've seen that the community is
experiencing the negative effects of
kind of terrorism laws so what I'd like
to ask is what is your government doing
to support and engage the vast majority
of Muslim community who are not engaged
in any terrorist activities and who want
to take a strong leadership role in this
tackle this issue I think the most
important thing we can do is literally
to engage with as you say the
overwhelming majority of British Muslims
who want nothing to do with the
supporting extremism and terror and one
of the things I think it's been really
impressive in in recent months and years
is when one of these outrages takes
place the first people to get out there
whether on Twitter or on the television
or radio or wherever is leaders of the
British Muslim community condemning what
has happened and I think that has been
incredibly powerful I saw President
Obama the other day actually highlighted
the not in my name hashtag campaign that
was on Twitter from British Muslims and
said that was an example to the whole
world but I think we need to do more to
explain to everybody that this is the
people we're talking about is a minority
of a minority it's a tight you know but
they are spreading a poisonous narrative
of extremism and terror that we've got
to fight the government doing anything
to actually engage with the leaders the
community as a mosque leaders to
actually take a heat you know a
responsibility and also a leadership
role because right now you've got the
prevent program that Ed Miliband
mentioned earlier is under the police
control leaders are not involved they're
not really part of this process they're
not really you're obviously right we
have we have the prevent program which
is more about trying to prevent people
from getting involved in terror and that
is more of a criminal justice sort of
intervention but then through the
Department of local government we
have a big engagement program with
British Muslim communities and British
Muslim leaders to talk to them about
these issues about how we fight as llama
phobia for how we include people better
in our country how we make sure that
when these appalling things happen
British Muslims are the first to come
out and condemn them so there is a good
program what my government did was it
split these two programs in apart on the
advice of a very senior actually Liberal
Democrat legislature who said they got
rather muddled and it was better to have
a prevent program to steer people away
from terror and then have an engagement
program through the Department of local
government to try and bring communities
closer together
okay we're gonna move on in sanitary
products profit free I just want to know
if you'd do the same is a really good
idea which university is that it's a
University of East Anglia University
what are you reading enjoying it yeah I
think is worthwhile we were going to
this conversation earlier about
universities and degrees you've
confident good it sounds like a great
idea
I think you just clarify you were saying
about removing be 80 yeah no sorry yes
yes this is a long-standing campaign I
have had a look at it in the past I
think it's quite difficult to some v80
things you can change other v80 things
if they're linked to other products it's
quite difficult to do it within the
framework of European laws and I can't
remember the answer so that's it but I
think I think I think it's very
difficult to do but I have to go away
and have a look we'll come back to
answer okay okay we're gonna go to a
Facebook question now from Daniel Green
what are your views on online voting and
do you think 16 17 year-olds should be
allowed to vote in elections right but
if you think I've said some unpopular
things so far wait for this I I'm afraid
I think the you've got to have one age
of majority and I think 18 is in my view
I understand the case for votes for 16
and 17 year-olds but my view is 18 is a
is a better age it's the age where so
many other things kick in and I think
it'll be better to save that voting age
for for 18 online voting I mean I don't
have any objection to it but I think in
a way we're asking the wrong question
you know the reason people don't vote is
not because it's too calm
gated to go down to the polling station
the reason people don't vote is they
don't think it makes enough of a
difference and so I think we ought to
focus on trying to make sure our
politics is delivering the things people
want rather than simply just trying to
work out how do we make it easier to
vote okay follow up on that or you say
that you know you don't think that on
voting is the right thing or is it
because politicians were afraid of what
would happen if people would vote from
home I don't have any I don't have any
great objection to it as I say but you
could have some people said why don't we
vote on a Sunday make it easier when
some people aren't working some people
say why don't we vote for you know three
days in a row rather than just one day
why don't we vote online we have more
postal voting these are all good ideas
to discuss but I think they the people
the reason people don't vote is not
because it's too complicated to go down
to the polling station so I think we're
slightly missing the point so I don't
have an objection to these methods if we
can make sure there's no fraud and all
the rest of it but I think it's not
really why people aren't voting okay
next question from flopping so it
follows on and so we're sort of talking
about what discourages people from
voting and I think for me something that
comes into play is that I kind of agree
with some policies of one party and
agree with other bits of another policy
so it's kind of hard to align myself
specifically with one party so now
looking at the coalition do you think
that cross party initiatives will kind
of be steering the progression of
democracy and government in the UK well
I mean a coalition was a bit of a new
departure we hadn't had one for 70 years
in our country and I I hope it showed
that when there isn't a decisive result
politicians can put aside their own
political interest and try and work
together that's where all the all the
ones you've heard from today we have
different views about all sorts of
things but we all actually love this
country we want to serve our country we
believe that our political system can
deliver that's what brings us together I
think one of the things we ought to try
and do is maybe more free votes more
occasions when Parliament isn't voting
because people are whipped by their
party to do so I also think we've had
quite a few referendums in recent years
and I think that's a good way to ask
people their view I think you ought to
all you know have a view on Europe and
whether we should stay in the European
Union we haven't had
vote on this in this country since 1975
and that's why I'm saying if I'm Prime
Minister in after May the 7th we'll have
a vote on that so that's one way to kind
of break down some of the party
strictures free votes in Parliament
we've got one tomorrow on whether you
should be able to transfer DNA and in
order to avoid some genetic diseases for
children that's a free vote more of
those maybe some more referendums okay
follow up on that from Holley disengaged
with voting and Natalie Bennett
mentioned earlier it's been a hundred
years since women got the vote nearly
and why aren't any parties taking it
seriously that women still are being
paid as much as men I feel like that's
why I mean if I was a woman looking at
voting if a party so that they were
going to take that seriously
they'd automatically have my vote and I
don't feel like well I I think I am
taking it seriously I think it's a very
important issue it's a scandal I mean
the pay gap for under 40s is now almost
gone so we've made some good progress it
shouldn't have taken so long but it has
almost gone over forties there's still a
pay gap and we need to address that
we've brought in this thing where any
company that is found to got this wrong
and a tribunal then has to have a pay
audit throughout their company to see
whether we can improve on the you know
to see whether they need to change all
their practices there are a lot of
things we need to do make childcare
easier and more affordable encourage
women back into the workforce after
they've had their children lots of
things we can do make sure Public
Appointments
more women are taking up make sure that
politics has got better representation
of women where my party was one of the
back markers for doing a bit better than
that and we need to keep at it convinced
you something okay well well maybe we do
some more convincing later if you want
to we're gonna go to a last question
from Charlie - hi Charlie and there we
go I don't know if you look around this
room people are engaged in politics come
from a multitude of backgrounds
however just 4.2 percent of MPs in the
hospital men's are from an ethnic
minority
despite 12.9% making up the population
just over one in five women and our MPs
in the House of Commons now given this
can we say that Parliament is a truly
representative institution and can
really trust you to create policies
encompass a concern of marginalized
groups I think the short answer your
question is today Parliament is not
properly representative of the country
it has changed and got better in that
there are now more women MPs and more
members of parliament from black and
minority ethnic communities but not
enough I mean my party is a good example
before the last election we had 17 women
MPs we've now got over 50 that's still
not enough when you think I've got 300
members of parliament but it's progress
before the last election we have very
few members of parliament from black and
minority ethnic groups we now have
British Sikhs British Asians black
British people on the conservative
benches the culture Secretary Sajid
Javid was a British Muslim full member
of the cabinet so you know for the
second generation immigrant so I think
we are making progress but we haven't
done enough but I think it's a really
important thing about our country that
actually people can come from other
parts of the world and in one or two
generations I want to see them be able
to sit around that cabinet table or be
captains of industry or senior judges in
the land it's happening and it's a
precious thing we've got but we've got
to push it harder and faster just one
last follow-up from just behind how are
you David you're talking about how
Parliament is not only not
representative but you said that
everyone should have a view but why
should 16 and 17 year olds have a view
if your party isn't willing to listen to
us isn't willing to understand and try
to take into consideration the fact that
things are being done towards us and
we're not being listened to because we
can't vote I think we should listen we
should listen to everyone in our country
but then we have a responsibility
members of parliament have a
responsibility to decide who gets to
vote now my view is that we should have
a vote on this I think it's time we
should vote on I still think 18 is the
right age because it's the age when so
many other things of majority happen but
it's a perfectly legitimate debate
whether it should be 16 17 or 18
personally I go for 18 and I find quite
strong support for that around the
country but let's by all means have the
have the debate and have the argument
well I I think we're gonna leave it
there answered a series of questions
from around
we appreciate your time probably sir
thank you very much that's it for this
session
thank you David Cameron that's 100 plus
the Prime Minister don't forget we'll
have a special program featuring all
four political party leaders on Sky News
at 8:30 tonight's if you still have
questions for mr. Cameron he'll be
answering those in a live facebook Q&A
as soon as he comes off the set we'll
have full analysis coming up and you can
join in the debate on social media just
use the hashtag ask the leaders